hello and welcome to New World review
the place where absolutely nothing bad
will happen trust me trust me we've been
so loyal to me so far so good to me with
these like and dislike buttons mostly
like buttons that you tippy-tap like a
happy pup you've been so very kind I
appreciate you all so very much
got you you fools why did you trust me
this can only end in your demise and
like my food here to give you a review
of episodes 15 and 16 mid teen teen time
so strap in prepare for spoilers and
feel free to leave that feedback down
below for Liam to deal with because I
certainly don't and I love to make more
work for him if and when I can episode
15 gave me chills we got genuine chills
folks I loved it
the audio was high chinked but I don't
actually care about that so much
we knew Tonpa was going to trick him
that was very obvious and very clear it
was a very long amusing way of giving
him the same lesson gone will likely
need to learn at some point for the
first time since we started I
legitimately felt bad for gone as a
child up against adults the moment the
man walked out of the bushes had me
holding my breath because they baited
and switched me I knew that it had to be
something that could happen but it
caught me anyway the feeling of concern
I got watching those butterflies around
gone and Hisoka was the concern of
someone who wondered how it could
possibly end let's reason this out a
little we know for a fact that we have a
passionate sociopath who is kind to
butterflies generally relaxed until
influenced by something else or someone
else and clearly and calmly enters every
situation with a sense of purpose and
surety of step if you think I was
talking about gone you'd be right but
not as right as the fact that I was
describing Hisoka both of these
characters being so similar present a
really nice balance for each other in
fact there is nothing I'm enjoying more
about this series than the professional
romance between Hisoka and gone-gone
strange child that he is simply steps up
to meet his rival with butterflies tied
to his finger at the beginning of that
episode I did wonder whether he was
going to be attempting to steal the
badge that day and while it wouldn't
have been past gone and while he could
have attempted by the end of the episode
I got more a sense that he didn't
necessarily plan on that rather he
wanted to watch his Sokka the way he had
watched the bird speaking of watching
the bird and butterflies I do wonder
whether there's any symbolism in the use
of flying animals here the beauty of the
butterflies with both characters in the
company in quiet calm soundscapes around
both gave me a very clear understanding
as a delicacy of movement and the
preparation of each character go and use
the butterflies much the way he uses his
fishing rod it made a lot of sense that
he would be very gentle with them as a
tool comparatively we saw Hisoka
appreciating them for what they were
gently watching them take off into the
sky as he had a discussion with his
inflatable person there's always so much
to be said about his Sokka I declare my
love for him on a weekly basis the
combination of extreme delicacy with
cutthroat and head and neck precision in
his attacks are quite wonderful and
looking at his attack style he's about
agility and avoiding being hit rather
than going into smash we very much have
a low-key type character than a Hulk and
I appreciate him for it it's easy to
imagine his childhood mocked and left
alone to raise himself he takes solace
in building card houses one day a bigger
kid in the schoolyard creates a minor
earthquake leading him to paper cut the
bully
unfortunately that paper cut is across
the jugular resulting in the bully's
death but no one could blame poor
pathetic Hisoka right but it's at that
moment that he learns his true power and
the passionate storm of flamenco music
begins in the background as he learns to
throw cards faster and faster anyway
while gone sociopathy could be related
to his dad disappearing we don't have
any indication of why his Sokka wants to
be a hunter beyond the obvious fact that
he would be good at it but would he he
doesn't know who he's supposed to be
hunting he's a known Russian has no
particular interest in the exam at this
point what does he want why is he doing
this this is the first time we haven't
really seen him doing anything not just
standing there not doing anything I mean
literally relaxing and doing nothing for
all my internal expectation that he
would belong in a city he seems very
comfortable and at home in nature and
that raises all sorts of questions for
me where is he from what did he do
before why does he want to be a hunter
which aspect of the exam has given him
the most satisfaction I love having
these questions and when the dying
examinee turns up I have a further
question why doesn't he just kill the
man he says himself that he only spares
those whose deaths would go to waste
surely it would be faster to kill the
man than bother dodging him at all
there's a strange sociopathic logic in
denying the man the right to a noble
death I suppose by the same token will
he spare God's life again is gone seen
as worthy does he remain worthy if he
attacks his socre a second time or
foolish does he see gone as a worthy
opponent does he know gone is after him
if he does that adds another layer of
intrigue because he's then providing
gone with all the information he needs
to beat his soca including the knowledge
that his percussionist ik teammate is
now sleeping in a hole that will become
very relevant I suspect and I simply
feel bad for the guy following kilowatt
to be honest he's not going to last long
but we'll see you in episode 16 oh my
episode 16 before we get into it I want
to quickly say that I didn't realize
there was a single woman involved in the
exam I suspect though I wouldn't know
without going back through every episode
I've seen so far that she was created
purely so they have to find a way to
beat her and all balance her abilities
against the audio I'll just leave that
thought there because it would totally
belong in a different series on the
creation and destruction of women in
anime along with Neon Genesis Evangelion
and Gorham like if you want it happy to
provide not here though back to episode
16 this episode was a romp through my
emotional range the minor key that we
got fer gone was a beautiful exploration
of gone as loser it's about time that
Gahan felt fear it's about time that
Gahan felt like the child he is and we
finally got that experience in this
episode working from the end to the
beginning I have to mention the
beautiful use of sound has gone sat in a
tree alone recovering the use of silence
and music in this episode was absolutely
everything as was the use of landscape
in nature God's perspective was very
much the perspective we saw this episode
and I adored every minute of it hisoka's
laughter echoing into the silence showed
us the sound of humiliation anger and
shame that echoed through God's mind and
it was superb it truly was time we got
another insight into his mind and after
the episodes where he felt so victorious
about being able to catch a bird we as
an audience I as an audience let me
speak for myself was so concerned
annoyed and amused that he hadn't
thought his plan through if I had been
watching this series as a younger person
than I am I might not have seen that
hole though there is a part of me
wondering whether it makes sense that a
series with such prominent boobage would
be specifically for children speaking of
minds
Hisoka who knew what number he needed or
bluffed his way through not knowing
which number he needed the art the art
his art the drawing of him standing
still the art style changing and the
darkness of the environment and
progression of time while he and Gahan
experienced their own thoughts and
emotions Gahan panicking but being
forced out of his panic
all of this was such incredible
storytelling that I feel this is
entirely and absolutely what the medium
was created for the use of sound and
movement in this moment is one of the
reasons for the manga series to be
turned into an anime
Hisoka doesn't move for two minutes but
in that time an incredible change comes
over him as he craves and hungers if I
didn't know better and I do so I'm
saying it he was aroused because that's
exactly what's depicted in this moment
of absolute stillness and it's what is
alluded to in the shape of his eye the
tongue the use of lust in the subtitles
as a distinct words blood I'd be
interested to know whether that's a
direct translation actually bloodlust in
English is a single word the delineation
could be a really subtle clever way of
acknowledging both his bloodlust his
desire to kill as well as the sexual
enjoyment he gets from doing so it seems
as though if we take that observation at
face value he craves bravery intelligent
bravery though not people doing things
because they're dangerous he appreciates
karateka and the audio so much that when
the time comes for them to stand up to
him despite knowing he could take them
on easily he doesn't he's fattening his
prey the sound involved in this moment
is both magical on those strings and
minor in key and I may be entirely
incorrect but still in keeping with his
flamenco I'm going to need musician
comments as to help me on this one
because there's a link between his
flamenco and the strings involved and I
think it's more than just the fact that
there are strings involved either way
the sense of passion and the fact that
this growth as it were happens at
sunrise is wonderful timing the
awakening of his arousal and desperation
and you know he's not going to get it
from his next target but he has to try
because he doesn't have a choice a point
worth noting is that as concerned as I
was for garden for a little while it
didn't escape my notice that he used
another as bait too he used the old man
as bait to prepare to take from Hisoka
and so despite trying to protect those
he considers friends he still lacks
empathy enough or is determined enough I
suppose you could say not to interrupt
and try to help the other man he knows
and says in fact that his soca will
attack the next person he sees he
doesn't try to help that man he simply
runs ahead and waits to attack and yes
we can say that it's okay for him to do
that those who are a part of the exam
know they are risking death to take part
but and
other hand gone can see the difference
in his sokka's posture and movement and
yet does nothing to try to mitigate that
gan recognizes in that moment the prey
his prey needs and hangs back just as
his predator does seven thousand times
on that point it was great that his
hunter came back but i still wonder why
his hunter decided to just watch yes he
says he was impressed but to me it seems
like a strange way to treat an exam
either way the treatment of angles in
this episode gave us the perspective of
multiple angles of prey and showed us
that the predator is not always who it
seems to be it was an enjoyable artistic
meal and I appreciated it for the entire
twenty minutes as a hunter perhaps those
elements of predator and prey is what
Hisoka hungers for and why he's taking
part in the exam a prey worth killing in
fact it's something he says to God he
wants nothing more than for God to
become strong enough to be worth killing
it seems the point at the exam for him
is to use the exam to find those worthy
of destruction rather than complete the
exam to be a hunter if that's the case
poor gone who knows at this point
undeniably that even if he finishes the
hunter exam it may not be because of his
own work it may be because he was
dragged through it by someone undeniably
stronger than him leaving on
psychological issues there that's all
from me if you enjoyed this video then
please do leave this video a like share
or subscribe and if you'd like to join
the fun then please do head over to the
discord server where a wide array of
shenanigan re takes place on a daily
basis and finally please do comment with
your thoughts on episodes 15 and 16 of
Hunter hunter this has been the New
World review and I'll see you next time